welcome back to launchpad I'm Christian
Reddy your friendly neighborhood
astronomer and I'm so glad that you are
able to join with us today I am here
today with a very special guest and
talking to you from the studio's of
launchpad enterprises all right or it's
my den whatever it is it doesn't matter
but I'm here today because a really cool
cat named Bryan Keating sent me this
book called losing the Nobel Prize and
the subtitle here is a story of
cosmology ambition and the perils of
Sciences highest honor please welcome my
guest dr. Bryan Keating Bryan hello it's
good so good to see you sir it's great
to be here and thank you so much
Christian so Bryan I was a saying this
to you earlier you know I've been
reading this book and I full disclosure
I haven't finished reading it yet but
I've been reading through it and the
best non-technical science books are the
ones that even though I teach the stuff
and I think just about everybody here is
aware of the basic subject matter the
fact that I can read a book about
something I'm supposed to know about or
at least presumably have some ideas of
and even some of the subjects that I
actually teach in my classes and I can
still read this and just be like total
page-turner mode that to me is the sign
of a fantastic book so I just want to
thank you for writing this and I'm so
glad that we could discuss it today
before we get into losing the Nobel
Prize I like to talk about losing the
new Nobel Prize and just kind of setting
it setting it up one thing that I'm
getting from this book Bryan is that
this is not a situation where obviously
as the title implies you had a shot at
the Nobel Prize you weren't able to get
there and it's not like well by I lost
the Nobel Prize and the Nobel Prize
sucks
sour grapes right we're not doing
anything like that what we're saying is
that there are some real problems with
the Nobel Prize it doesn't mean he
didn't want it and doesn't mean you
weren't doing some incredible science
with it but what I'd like to ask you
first is since the book is called losing
the Nobel Prize you had some problems so
he had some concerns as I have with the
Nobel
prai's only I'd like to ask if you could
first just discuss some of those yeah
well the book is sort of written as a as
a memoir more than even a popular
science book and I want to take readers
through this journey that I went on in
many different dimensions both in terms
of trying to understand what the origin
of the universe might have looked like
if indeed first taking a step back what
if there wasn't a single origin of the
universe it's one of the deepest
mysteries I think that the human mind
can attempt to comprehend and technology
is poised to let us possibly unravel and
trying to come up with an idea to do
that and win a Nobel Prize to boot was a
huge motivation for me as a young you
know 30-something 20 some 20-something
postdoc which is sort of what you do
after you get your PhD and you want to
be a professor someday sort of a
purgatory position that some parlay into
actual faculty positions that I was
lucky enough to do and the ultimate goal
of this experiment was to unravel the
origins of the universe and along the
way I was caught up in this desire is
I'm quite candid to admit in the in the
book of wanting to win the Nobel Prize
coming close to winning it by courtesy
of an experiment that I invented with
colleagues at Caltech and elsewhere in
the early 2000s and then having it
upgraded this was placed the South Pole
Antarctica I'll fold in some images
there in a second but the main goal of
this project was to glimpse the
beginning of time epoch known as
inflation and along the way we claimed
that we did it and actually we were
successful and we and made this
announcement on st. Patrick's Day 2014 I
point out and green beer had nothing to
do with the announcement nor its
subsequent retraction because you know
spoiler alert the book is called losing
the Nobel Prize not winning the Nobel
Prize there are actually a few books
about you know how to win a Nobel Prize
that I say are about is like lucky and
useful as you know how to win lotto or
bingo strategies that pay off this was
not something that I had really
encountered before so I wanted to write
a book about what it's like to aspire to
greatness come a little bit short
and and induct yourself off literally
and move on to hopefully learn lessons
have humility and take science a little
bit further than it could have been
otherwise you know I think III think
that's again another hallmark of this
book it's really you know it's it's a
it's a story not just of scientific
success because I think it's really fair
to say you've had some of considerable
successes in your career but also yeah
you know hey we had to retract something
and science doesn't always get
everything right it's a process it takes
time to get there and I think that's
just great that you're taking that
candor and your that humility and you're
just putting pen to paper and and
telling this story so let's delve into
the story just a little bit more and
obviously I think many of our viewers
here have some ideas to what we're all
talking about but there's also a lot of
things that are going on that in this
book that require a little bit of
clarification and backstory and I
thought maybe we could just start off
since you know if Tony Darnell's channel
by the way Tony if you're watching he
has the you ought to be taking a look at
deep astronomy make sure you are
subscribed but if Tony's channel is sky
and telescope mine's astronomy magazine
right have a slightly different audience
but that's all cool and let's talk about
what it is that you're searching for why
were you I'm not asking why you were
seeking the Nobel Prize every scientist
would love to have that but what were
you doing what what question were you
trying to answer yeah so first let me
give a shout out to Tony and let
listeners know I think that's how you
and I met Christian a few months maybe
even last year now it seems like a
hundred years ago with the Cova the
situation oh my god but I was on his
show maybe late early this year perhaps
and then we I reached out to you you
reached out to me and we put this
together and now I'm pleased to announce
that Tony and I are doing weekly
fireside book chats where we're talking
about books that I'm reviewing along
with interviews with there are authors
for my channel so I run a podcast called
the into the impossible podcast and I
put videos up on my youtube channel
just today we have a video up that I did
an interview with Peter Diamandis
the famous X Prize and singularity
University famous entrepreneur physician
a futurist about his book called the
future is closer than you think
or is faster than you think we've done
interviews with the leading minds of
astronomy ranging from Roger Penrose to
to the late great Freeman Dyson and
everyone in between so look forward to
that I have an interview with Stephen
Wolfram that's getting viral degrees of
hits and that's great and soon I'll have
one with Eric Weinstein so I like to
talk to the biggest brightest minds in
astronomy and learn from them because
although I'm a full professor now I will
always consider myself a scholar and the
things that have always interests me
most are the biggest questions of all
the meaning behind questions such as why
is there something rather than nothing
why is the universe the way it is what
caused life to emerge from non-life that
had to have happen what caused
consciousness to emerge from simple life
forms these are the biggest questions
that a human mind can comprehend in my
opinion though it's you know there's
certainly many worthy questions in
science and outside of science for me
those are the questions I want to most
know the answers to or contribute to
before I leave this mortal coil and so
part of the book is as really like what
do I do as an astronomer to answer those
questions so it's not enough to just
think about those questions and be you
know puzzled by them in my way because I
wanted to do this for a job and and also
contribute to the Scholastic lineage
that I was a beneficiary sorry yeah what
I wanted to really do most of all is
answer the question what came before the
Big Bang if if such a question could be
answered some people say that the late
great Stephen Hawking who Peter
Diamandis was his flight surgeon we
talked a little bit about that in the
video when he took a zero gravity flight
in the vomit comment about ten years ago
the great astronomer Stephen Hawking
said that the question of what was there
before the Big Bang is meaningless
because time came into existence with
the
but there many scientists who believe
that not only is that not true there
actually could have been perhaps an
infinite number of universes that
pre-existed predated what we call the
observable universe today and though
that was the exact crisp formulation of
the question that I attempted to answer
by designing conceiving of this
experiment called bicep which is behind
me on the cover of the book
it's a telescope located at the very
bottom of the world the South Pole
Antarctica which I point out if you
really want to get away from kovat if
you really want to escape your creditors
the IRS you know whoever your boss go
down to the South Pole because nobody
has koba down there the entire continent
is Kovac free the catch is you had to
get there you know before February 1st
and you have to stay there until
November but as I say you get paid
$75,000 and you just have to work one
night nice work
it's a nice six months but hey you know
it's still nice so one night that's
right for our astronomy friends they
they can get it and so to build this
experiment took years of human effort
and many many of the most brilliant
people in the world working together as
a team with a leader taking it down to
the South Pole and going through life
and astronomy and competition all to
unravel this fundamental question which
really comes down to as I discuss in the
book was there a singular beginning of
time and can we rule out multiple Big
Bang's the observations of what's called
the cosmic microwave background
radiation and this is this temperature
that pervades the universe in all
directions it comes from the fiery
forging of the elements in the beginning
of time and that that pattern has been
measured over the years since 1965 by
you know dozens of experiments but the
most sort of interesting aspect of it is
how did it come to be why does it look
the exact way that it looks I'll try to
put a picture up here and a second
behind me of exactly what the background
looks like if you were sort of God
looking at it you know from from the
outside perspective of an
and being looking at our universe but in
the case of this this beautiful pattern
that we see in all directions here I'll
put it up now so there it is behind me
this is a famous image of from w map
mm-hmm and the Planck images are very
similar as well
and this shows tiny ripples called
wrinkles in space-time itself places
were gravity matter energy where higher
or lower and we're color coding them red
or blue depending on if they're colder
or hotter on average than the 2.7 to 6
degree average black body temperature
those regions that are colder will have
morphed into clusters of galaxies which
by virtue of their mass will have
greater pull and therefore diminution of
the photons energy as they stream
towards us they appear colder conversely
images where there's less matter appear
hotter those are the red spots but the
main question that we're always trying
to answer in physics is what are the
initial conditions of the system how did
the system get to be where it is today
is crucially dependent on how did it
begin in the case of the Big Bang we
have no idea exactly what took place at
time equals 0 that's what my experiment
was guaranteed hopefully not guarantee
it was designed to do we claimed we did
do it and then in a stunning turn of
events had to essentially retract our
interpretation of what we had seen Wow
ok that that so I'm glad we can unpack
all that and and clarify and there are
no new questions to be asked except
every every question it's running
through my head right now but I think it
would be good to maybe just talk a
little bit briefly about you mentioned
that the Cosmic Microwave Background as
you said it's it's this is the well it's
the leftover radiation from the Big Bang
it's what the Big Bang cooled down to as
you know 13.8 billion years later
however you mentioned in the in the W
map data behind you that there is some
variation in that temperature we say
it's 2.7 to 6 but it's not uniform it's
not completely uniform and how what kind
of a difference are we talking about
between you mentioned warmer regions and
colder regions what kinds of a
difference are we talking about here
so the hottest regions which again
appear as
red and those are places where there are
fewer photons so you know over my
shoulder here ish you know it's like I'm
a weatherman you know I always say that
the easiest job in the world of the San
Diego weatherman and the hardest job in
the world of San Diego sportscaster but
we'll leave that aside so when you look
at the red spots you're seeing something
that's perhaps six hundred micro Kelvin
so micro degrees Celsius or Kelvin
different from this blue spot that I'm
trying to point to over here the
fluctuations range basically between
plus and minus a couple of hundred micro
Kelvin riding on top of a 2.7 Kelvin
average temperature from the rest of the
universe and I should say I have done
something a little bit of a trick here
and this map from W map what what they
showed here is they showed just the
microwaves that you would see all over
the entire sky but it's not really a
representation of what is really there
in other words has been processed very
heavily in the most important way that
it's been processed is it's removed the
Milky Way galaxy so now check out this
map behind me running down the middle
here across horizontally is a bright
reddish orange stripe right you can see
that Christian yes I can very clear so
that stripe is the Milky Way galaxy as
would be seen by microwave eyes so if
you had microwave vision you look up you
wouldn't see a milky glow you'd see the
lynsee orange either but you'd see a
high intensity very very bright image of
the Milky Way galaxy and at different
wavelengths you'd see stronger or weaker
degrees of this band going across the
middle so this is at the highest
frequency where dust and other
contaminants in our galaxy are much much
brighter than the CM B's average
temperature and in the end these are
called foregrounds they're very
interesting to study the galaxy in its
own right but what we're looking for is
we want to see the entire universe that
is not unique or specific to the Milky
Way galaxy in other words we want to see
the cosmos the true cosmic signal that
pervades the universe not something just
quote-unquote unique to our own galaxy
so the answer question these ripples are
faint or parts per hundred thousand so
yeah if you ball I don't know do you
look like a guy who would ball because
you got this this Beautif
rumpus room when I used to call it
rumpus frenzy there a bowling ball
somewhere in there Christian I wish I
had one
all right well III but I know what
bowling ball I'm going to eventually get
it's going to have that C and B on it
because you can't not just you know what
I did I had a friend he has a 3d
printing business
it's called hop town handles shout out
to Ben Weston he made a beer handle with
a sphere with this image imprinted on it
for my my home keg where I have the
graduate students come on over okay put
your reader in the mold will talk about
that mate don't forget forget this
cosmology stuff I got a talk with you
right now
well the back will go back to that later
fight so so yeah but you'd be your tub
at the bowling analogy so if you look at
a bowling ball or a pool ball the
billiard ball those balls have tiny
fluctuations are not perfect spheres you
know from from Plato's cave they have
tiny imperfections variations in them as
does the surface of the earth the earth
is not a perfect sphere as I'm sure you
know there's variations in it the
variations in the amount of energy
difference on the microwave sky that
you're looking at those fluctuations are
smaller than the fluctuations in the
average height if you will our average
radius of a bowling ball in other words
the universe is smoother absent for the
gout and galactic signal let you see
across the middle the rest of the
universe is smoother in a microwave
sense than a bowling ball is in terms of
its average fluctuations Wow
so you're looking for these incredibly
tiny imperfections and these have been
detected as I said they began to be
detected in the early 90s more
detections of the very small scale
features remain in the early 2000s
exactly 20 years ago this week the first
announcement by boomerang that they had
detected the small scale structure was
announced and then finally the and I
talked a lot about boomerang in the book
because it was run by my late post
doctoral advisor and relying personal
side of the book and then we eventually
got to wonder well where do these
fluctuations come from where these tiny
little variations these ripples actually
come from you can't just say oh they
were born that way this is not the way
that the physics of the early universe
works
right that's what bicep was designed to
do so
we are n to beat you know again just to
just to clarify when we look at the
microwave background we are really
seeing a signal that comes to us from
the first light of the universe back
when the universe was I think what about
300,000 or so years old approximately
380,000 years okay
so we're seeing that light and obviously
it's it's still cooling down right and
it's you know it's gonna keep going down
and and so what you are effectively
looking at that portrait behind you is
effectively what the universe looks like
- the Milky Way excuse me it's a really
important caveat - look right that's
kind of what the universe was doing back
then and it's extremely smooth but as
you say it's just as smooth as a it's
smoother than a smoothest cue ball or
bowling ball but it's not perfectly
smooth there are these tiny fluctuations
one part in 100,000 in temperature so
that that brings us to where I think
that's where you come in if you're
trying to figure out okay what was going
on before that just to clarify we can't
see past that can we right yeah we
cannot see past that surface it's like
you can't see through a mirror amazing
light but you could hear something
happening on the other side of the
apartment wall or the rumpus room wall
you can hear it and that was the key
that I realized along with colleagues
that if you use something other than
light you could actually peer through
this surface behind that you could go
beyond that and going beyond that means
going to earlier in earlier times
possibly back to when these patterns
were imprinted by a force of nature that
is yet undetected called inflation so
you're looking for these acoustical
signatures of inflation now let's talk a
little bit about inflation right so we I
think we're all familiar with the Big
Bang
all right everything was squeezed up
into a very very tiny volume and you
know out it went at least that's that
may be a very first order even as new
earth order interpretation of it but you
know we know that our universe was very
very compact very very hot very dense
about 13.8 billion years ago
give or take some change
so where does inflation come into this
why why do we need to invoke something
called inflation don't we already have a
big bang and don't big bangs make
universes that's a very good question so
usually you hear about things in a straw
Ronnie might hear about yeah the theory
of evolution in in biology or in
astronomy you might hear about the Big
Bang but you don't stop to think that
that theory came about as a proposed
solution to another problem an earlier
problem and that's typically what
happens you have scientists what they
elect what we love to do is look back
and we look at where are the problems in
our theories where are they incomplete
we don't say ah that's a great theory of
gravity by Newton let's stop there you
know because if you do then you miss out
on something which might hold a more
fundamental or more pervasive truth in
the case of gravity of course that's
Albert Einstein's theory well guess what
Albert Einstein's theory had as one of
its predictions a type of creation event
which he abhorred in the early universe
that that later became known as the Big
Bang and that was proposed and he it was
a consequence directly of some simple
assumptions about the universe that had
caused none other than Einstein himself
to postulate the existence of something
called the cosmological constant which
he allegedly said was his biggest
blunder turned out not to be and now we
know it's actually correct all right
that guy exactly I let go you know I
always say it's too bad cuz it could
have had a good career if he didn't make
so many blunders yeah but but in reality
what we look at is when we look at the
early universe we even with the Big Bang
model have problems understanding why is
the universe looking like this so let me
look over my left shoulder over here so
I look over my left shoulder and over
here you'll see a blue spot I told you
that blue spot is pretty is pretty cold
right that blue spot might be 300 micro
Kelvin below 2.7 Kelvin so it's a cold
spot and then I look over my left my
right shoulder and there's another blue
spot with the exact same temperature but
these two spots in the sky my right
thumb and my left thumb you can see
those two spots are farther away
then the age of the universe multiplied
by the speed of light so think about
that for a second so that means that a
never could have been in contact with
each other in other words they never
could have been thermally in equilibrium
like a thermos you know full of warm
whisky no it was just water water but
yeah but but you couldn't they could
never have been at the same exact
temperature through thermal equilibrium
through the process of thermodynamics
right there's just not enough time for
them to get so far away from each other
had they been initially in what we call
causal contact right by the speed of
light between - yes yeah right when
Stein used to say it's not only a good
idea it's the law
right the law of relativity so you can't
go faster than that speed so then how
can it be that these two things are at
the exact same temperature and I use
analogies in the book you know it's like
it's like you know selecting out of a
room full of a whole store you know go
to Home Depot and there's a billion
toasters there they were all set at
random but they all have the exact same
temperature after cooling off for a tiny
bit of time that's very improbable
unless there was a conspiracy a couple
hours earlier when the shop keeper and
you can call the shopkeeper God or
nature or you know Alan Guth or whoever
you want and you could say that person
or some that agent tuned them to have
the exact same properties exactly at the
right time so that effectively they were
in thermal equilibrium at an earlier
time that's now been hidden from our
view because of the vast expansion of
space-time itself and that's called
inflation so inflation came along to
rectify the problems in the Big Bang the
Big Bang came along to rectify the
problems in the steady-state model and
the steady-state model had come along to
you know reconcile problems that Isaac
Newton had noticed in the eternal
universe and it just keeps going back
and back Christian and we're part of
this this you know storytelling chain
and we're trying to understand our piece
of the chain as well as we can with the
technology that we have today for me
that was to develop this experiment
called bison so that's what I want to
talk about next with you Brian but
before we before we do that the first I
have been remiss and I haven't welcomed
all of the
the fantastic people that are joining us
today online I told you I'm still
learning how to how to do this whole
livestream thing and maybe one day I'll
figure out how to make videos too and
we'll see but anyway I do want to say
hello and a warm welcome to everybody
watching I without also not to the
police of which special shout out to
surrogacy for his five euro super chat
thank you so much as well as path medic
for his five dollar super jet this a
pack medic says enjoying and
appreciating this thank you in case we
get called out before it's over
and I Christian from surrogacy a little
support to you for a Nobel Prize or
maybe he meant Nobel Prize I'm not sure
I had and also without special thanks to
urban explorer Neil Neil see Peter Quinn
is here it's always a it's never a live
stream until Peter Quinn shows up that's
kind of become my motto Stewart MacLean
and we also have here
Harley pebbly good to see you welcome
and hello
oh do you know every it's a new fear we
have Kate oh if cabin Kaelin Crabill one
of my students hi professor holo Kaelin
it's great to see you well done
Astro imagers here and thank you all so
much for coming along here today if I
haven't sounded you out yet it's purely
because I can't seem to scroll and read
and talk at the same time but thank you
all so much for dropping by here so uh
let's talk a little bit about well you
know what I'd like to throw a question
to you coming from the chat Brian if if
you don't mind and then I'd like to talk
about your I like to talk about your
experiment so let's say the question
that we have here comes from moser 1977
how could a very dense universe expand
in the beginning when we don't see the
solar system expand today so how can the
University expanding if everything
around here seems to be holding together
yeah so the question about expansion
really relies on whether or not the
universe is whether or not different
aspects of the universe or objects in
the universe are located in what's
called the Hubble flow so there
just as when with you know chemistry or
something like that where atoms are
influenced much more by local forces the
local electric charges or quantum
mechanical forces within the atom are
much more important than even the
strongest you know particle accelerator
in the world located at CERN say that's
so far away it doesn't have enough of an
influence to overcome the effects of a
local force you know it's really
important if you happen to be located in
the center of the Large Hadron Collider
but in but in astronomy when we talk
about expansion we really mean about
galaxies so the the solar system is not
expanding earth is not expanding
what's expanding is the average distance
of galaxies located at a distance far
enough so that they are participating in
the expansion of the universe that was
kicked off in the Big Bang if you will
and may be driven to this day by what's
called dark energy but it is not
occurring in the size scale of the earth
the moon the solar system or even you
know within our galaxy itself really
even if you look at the Andromeda galaxy
the Andromeda galaxy isn't expanding
away from us at all so if all we could
see is the Andromeda galaxy we'd see all
these galaxies are coming towards us but
in reality once you get beyond a few
galaxies distant neighbors you know
beyond the Andromeda galaxy you get out
to a region where all galaxies are
moving away from you so in other words
galaxies with the exception about a
handful maybe ten to a hundred galaxies
there are a hundred billion galaxies
that we know in the observable universe
all 999 million of them they are all
billion 99 million nine hundred nine
thousand etc they are all moving away
from us every single one so it's like if
you're in a city and you heard all the
ambulances in the city you heard their
sirens and they're all being redshifted
they're all like lower in pitch where
they would all be moving away from you
you would say except for a couple you
would say there must have been some
accident that happened where I'm
standing and now all these ambulances
are fleeing the scene and they're
getting red shifted as we say in
astronomy they are being lowered in
frequency that means that they're moving
away via the Doppler shift and so your
your question is a good one and it
applies for every galaxy beyond a few
times the distance to enjoy
wonderful and thank you and so uh I'm
just making sure I've got my visuals up
here so I'm playing an animation right
now just to give people some perspective
on and actually I think by the time this
comes here we've got a little latency
but just trying to illustrate that
illustrate the expansion of the universe
so really what we're saying is that
expansion is a well to borrow term a
global phenomena at least global
throughout the universe but on the
shorter scales of let's say our solar
system we don't notice it that much so
thank you for that and also would like
to thank Graham Jordan thank you so much
for the super chat Oh 20 year old that
was very generous of you thank you so
much they're really do appreciate your
support and what I'd like to do is ask
you well I do have yeah to come back to
the question in a moment but I do want
to talk about your experiment and what
you were looking for so now we
understand that yes we have a big bang
yes we have we need to have inflation
inflation solves that problem so we have
a working theory how do you test that
and I think that's where you really rise
up here and this is where you build the
bicep okay tell us a little about the
bicep experiment oh and I mean for those
that can see the image on the screen is
as a seen live shot from the South Pole
now it's not live is a picture at the
South taken at the South Pole when I was
there I've been there twice moving mr.
so this behind my behind my right
shoulder over right shoulder it's so
that's the outhouse by the way everyone
always asks how do you go to the
bathroom in space really a good question
how to go to the bathroom at the South
Pole and this is the answer there's an
outhouse down there and it's it's not
heated it's heated solar and during the
summer and they paint it black but
here's my experiment bicep and bicep is
an experiment an acronym which stands
for background imaging of cosmic
extragalactic polarization the big dish
farther oft in that direction is the
South Pole telescope that's a 10 meter
diameter telescope bicep even though
this is kind of cone-shaped thing like a
dog cone looks like it's very big
compared to even the South Pole
telescope actually the telescope itself
is tiny
sits inside of this ground screen inside
this blue building beyond me and that's
where I was located we deployed it there
in December of 2005 and it lasted
basically research of this type is going
on to this very day with an instrument
called the bicep array so it's going on
15 years now it's quite astounding to
think of a tiny idea that I had is being
continued to the very moment that we're
speaking over you know two decades
basically into our third technically
into our third decade right so this
experiment was designed to detect
inflation so inflation purports to
determine whether or not there was a
primordial field called a called a
quantum field that could have provided
enough explosive energy to cause the
universe to expand exponentially you
know before this year very few I
explained to people at Exponential's
were but now everybody knows that I
don't even have to mention it but the
the discovery that it was attempting to
make was that this field propelled the
universe with enough energy to expand
fast enough that later on we would then
impute the fact that these two regions
that I pointed to earlier could have
actually been in causal contact but
because of this enormous exponential
inflation they get separated faster than
the speed of light so they actually
moved away from each other faster than
the speed of light and that explains why
they got the great distances from one
another that can't be explained if they
only traveled at the speed of light the
catch is they could only travel faster
than the speed of light well as long as
space-time itself is expanding faster
than the speed of light and that could
only happen under very very important
circumstances that are driven by
something that I call a scalar field or
is known as a scalar field and we're
trying to detect the kind of shrapnel
from this from this very explosive like
expansion that lasted for a trillionth
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second so 10 to the minus 36 seconds
that's what inflation claims it can do
and what we're trying to detect are the
leftover sort of you know the treatise
as I'm saying from the from the early
universe that would present itself in a
way that
we could attempt to measure and that
measurement or that type of type of
measurement that we could we could
possibly hope to measure would look a
little bit limitless if I can get this
up here
would be in the form of waves of gravity
so presumably all of your listeners are
familiar with the so called LIGO
experiment which measured which measured
waves of gravity that came in to the
observatories in in Washington State and
in Louisiana and those waves of gravity
physically shook up the the detectors
and made them vibrate in a particular
characteristic way that's called a
direct detection when a gravitational
wave comes in shakes up your container
your laboratory and you measure the
shake up is less than a thousandth of
the diameter of an atom's of a nucleon
so we're incredibly small what we're
looking for is shaking up the universe
and its earliest phases and causing this
kind of particular pattern of
polarization of the orientation of the
oscillation plane of the photon and call
that polarization I go through in the
book what that is exactly so it was
predicted exactly as I said Christian it
was predicted that if inflation took
place we would see particular patterns
like these over here whether it's red or
blue where you see the swirling twisting
pattern called curl pattern of
polarization that's why the name bicep
came into play right you you do curls
with your bicep so that's why I thought
of that name but if you look at that
pattern this is actually an image that
we made and released on the on this
famous st. Patrick's Day event in 2014
and the logic that we were employing was
that of everybody that if you saw the
swirling twisting pattern called B mode
signal at the top that would mean that
we had detected the aftershocks of
inflation by way of gravitational waves
imprinting the Cosmic Microwave
Background so in other words the Cosmic
Microwave Background photons are
our detector and we're imaging how
polarized they became and in what way do
they swirl or twist and in doing so we
then made the claim that we had detected
the earliest physical direct evidence of
inflation it was actually indirect
evidence but we detected indirectly that
inflation must have taken place and more
than that the very same headlines in The
New York Times and writers such as Max
tegmark and Lawrence Krauss or claiming
that this was not only detection of
gravitational waves which hadn't been
detected in 2014 indirectly or directly
are they been texted indirectly but not
directly LIGO had not announced its
results from more than a year after that
it would also be detection of inflation
and 99% of all physicists thought it
would also be evidence for what's called
the multi-verse
that we are actually not the only
universe that possibly exists so not had
tremendous ramifications beyond my
wildest dreams as a young you know
20-something postdoc it had impact and
it had had potential ramifications for
everything from philosophy you know to
to religion certainly in terms of
astronomy and science so it really was
beyond my wildest dreams and on that
very day we were announced that we were
soon to win a very shiny sparkly prize
whoa
and I think we can talk about that so
again and I apologize folks it looks
like you lost my voice I had my
microphone muted because I don't want to
have any sounds getting through while
Bryan was speaking but in case you're
wondering what I was doing when I was
gesturing what I was saying is the poll
I was just basically clarifying
polarization so that at least I can
understand that right I always think of
light as you know like and light as a
wave and it can you know wave at you in
this direction it could wave at you in
this direction it could wave in any
arbitrary direction what if reflects off
of something usually waves only
oscillate in one particular direction
that's a measure of the polarization
that's all around was that's what that's
where he was going with this and I just
want to mention but you already knew
that I was just saying it so that I knew
that and he sounded like I had some
ideas don't know what I'm talking about
but anyway yeah okay I put myself on
camera yeah I'm still figuring them one
of these days I forget about you know
Brian um what I thought we could talk
about is you're there you're now just
about to get that Nobel Prize you have
you have detected the actual pre-pack
seen evidence of inflation you've showed
that Alan Guth was right but then what
happened yeah so we made this
announcement we had claimed that we had
you know basically seen what was called
the face of God if you felt that you
were you know a religious person that we
had been waiting for this detection for
for so long
and-and-and actually we made this
announcement that we that we had been
successful and so the thing that we had
looking for been looking for is what we
had actually discovered so isn't that
great and you know that's something that
you almost never experience in science
let alone you know the such fanfare when
you're looking for something and you
come up with it and I mentioned you know
along the way that I had thought about
well does the universe have this kind of
expansionary phase to it to explain the
problems that were located in the Big
Bang itself and I never really thought
we would be successful I actually
thought we would be unsuccessful and but
it was still an interesting story to
tell but in the end when we started to
look at what was the true nature of the
signal that we saw we had questions we
had doubts we didn't know if what we
would see would be a pristine image or
remember back to the earlier images that
I showed before you know whether or not
the universe would have this dusty
component or this foreground component
in it that would manifest itself even
though we chose a clean region in the
sky in this map it was sort of the
region is just to my sholder word so the
mostly blue we looked in a region of the
sky that's far away from the galaxy
below the galaxy and what's called the
Galactic southern hemisphere right
you're just trying to avoid all that
interferes from from our galaxy
basically right because that are we knew
that our galaxy could produce what's
called what's called polarization
spurious polarization from this
the foreground emission in our galaxy
and in fact now I'm showing just the
image that we saw and we knew that there
was a possibility that there could be
contamination from in particular from
dust but we didn't have a sensitive
channel that could measure dust and the
Cosmic Microwave Background there was
one group that did have it they were
located on a satellite there called the
Planck satellite and the Planck
satellite what had been a billion euro
experiment that had been launched you
know around the same time as we had
started coming up with the idea for
bicep and we wanted to beat them to the
punch because this is huge science that
we're trying to do we were doing it you
know for less than 1% of their budget
and they were claiming that they are
gonna make this detection and really you
know startle the world because it would
be the first detection of this you know
really concrete smoking gun evidence for
inflation so we were in a race with them
and we knew that they actually had the
goods that we needed they had the data
that would show whether or not you know
what we were seeing was dust or whether
or not it was I was truly from the
primeval universe so the day we made the
announcement of course you know like I
said there was great fanfare everybody
said we're gonna win you know this the
shiny metal over here behind me and it's
most coveted prize in all of the world I
claim I mean there's way more Olympic
gold medallist and there are Nobel
laureates in physics and so everybody
wanted to win it so we asked them can
you please share your data they hadn't
published it yet and they refused and I
took that to mean that they had the
goods and that they were gonna beat us
to the punch
and so it really put us into a panic
mode at least I was panicking are they
gonna scoop us or not and we sort of had
to do whatever we could to get our best
understanding of whether or not the
signal we could we saw was pristine you
know kinda like this one with no
galaxies or whether it was not whether
it was contaminated with filth with us
but to treat us from the from the origin
and death of stars in our in our own
local galaxy not in the universe itself
and so the book is called losing the
Nobel Prize you can kind of guess what
happened that's not really the whole
story because what happened
was you know and we talked about this I
talked about this in the book how the
ups and downs of that experience of you
know knowing that we have this of rumors
leaking of you know battling against
gainst the universe itself but also with
competitors that are also trying to get
to the same answer to you know to get
the same accolades that we are and only
three people at most can win the Nobel
Prize so it was extremely stressful
period I talk about that and I talk
about the stresses on individuals within
the group and people that I know and
loved and and and how that affects you
as a human being so it's a science story
it's talking about the physics behind
the images that we saw and how we got to
on the understanding that we had by
standing on the shoulders of giants to
really understand the the basics the
essence of the extremely early universe
but again it's also sort of a detective
story and an a personal memoir at that
so you had seen this signal it was
pretty clear in terms of what you were
looking at but you were lacking some
additional information from the Planck
satellite and they were not prepared to
share that with you at the time what I'd
like to ask then is what and forgive me
if you've already said this and I just
missed it while I was switching windows
around but what happened how did how did
those distinct curls suddenly not hold
up anymore yeah so you were a couple
minutes ago we were talking about you
know polarization and what can cause
polarization the signal that we're
looking for is this polarization signal
and what I'm what you were you know
basically trying to attempt to describe
as I described in the book is yes is
shown by this image here soft yeah look
at the image behind me you'll notice
here I'm gonna stop completely out of
the frame here if you lose no you're
good you're good
okay so here
so here's light coming from the Sun it's
made up of what's called unpolarized
light that unpolarized light strikes the
ocean here in San Diego and one of those
modes of polarization gets suppressed
the vertically oriented polarization
gets suppressed and what's left is
horizontal only polarization
and what sunglasses do when you have
polarized sunglasses they absorb that
layer that's reflected now why do you
want to absorb that because otherwise
you're gonna see a reflection from the
Sun that's gonna be very bright it's
going to cause glare but the lesson to
take away from this is that even when
something occurs is produced that is
that is unpolarized say light from the
Sun is unpolarized blackbody radiation
when that interacts with matter here
it's shown as the oceans surface right
so there's ocean surface when it hits
the ocean surface it becomes polarized
and so to whenever light interacts with
matter it can become polarized and that
polarization process when it occurs can
be of this pattern that can lead you to
believe that it is that it came from the
early universes inflationary epoch when
it really came from interaction with
something prosaic here water reflecting
sunlight which is actually something we
have to worry about not water there's no
water at the South Pole right good water
but snow we have to worry about
polarization so2 in the galaxy
there's polarized light everywhere
coming from the interaction of star
light produced by stars in the inner
galaxy just in the infrared or in the
visible light and they can produce mm a
light signal when they when they that
unpolarized light is just like star like
our Sun is just producing star light
right so it can produce a polarized
signal via these processes I'm going to
show you in a second and it's reflecting
light off of dust and how that occurs is
is really fascinating so what dust does
dust can do one of two different things
it will focus really on the on the
picture on the so you look at the
picture over my shoulder there it says
unpolarized light that's coming from a
star then it hits a dust particle and
then what happens is that filters out
light just like the sunglasses filtered
out the on one of the unpolarized light
because you see the dust particles are
little football shaped you tend to
absorb the horizontal light more than
the vertical light so in this image the
vertical light gets transmitted to our
detectors which would be located off off
off to my right shoulder here it's
mirrored so it's hard and that would
then be detected by biceps so a dust
particle can produce polarization from
an unpolarized light source now where
did that dust come from well that dust
comes from the after-effects of a dead
star in the interstellar medium in our
own galaxy so when a star dies in a
supernova spews its material out into
the galaxy and that light can become or
those particles can then scatter
interacting with unpolarized light to
produce exactly the signal that we saw
and that's what we think actually ended
up happening producing the swirling
twisting patterns of microwaves that we
thought were indicative of the
inflationary origin and it turned out to
be more than likely foreground dust in
the Milky Way the whole time yeah
there's been such a disappointment to
have to cover that realization and and
the hits didn't the hits didn't stop
there I mean that was I know that's the
big hit of the book but there are a few
others that you talked about and you got
some horrible news when you were at the
South Pole you're already in a very
unforgiving environment and then you've
found some almost perhaps equally
horrible news when you were back in San
Diego I was all ready to talk about that
for a moment else what happens so as I
said the book is also a memoir it's not
only a book about about you know the
science popular science trade book as
it's often called and so you know kind
of opened the book on the early chapters
talking about being here the dream of my
life to build an experiment that could
take us back to the very origin of time
itself and while I was there at least in
the first time I went down there I got a
phone call from my older brother who
told me that in no uncertain terms my
father had a serious cancer and that he
wasn't likely to live and you're
basically trapped at the South Pole even
in the summertime it could take two
weeks to a month to get back to
California so it was really startling to
me to have to be kind of summoned away
you know to fulfill these you know the
obligations that I owed to my father and
it ended up turning out my mother also
came
at the same time so it's really
devastating and so dealing with that and
especially now it's covin like teaching
my kids teaching that graduate students
you know I used to think it's the dream
job to be a professor it's it's it's
very challenging it's very rewarding to
be a scientist but it's not all stroking
you know your non-existent beard and and
just you know dreaming about adding some
decimal place on to something that's
that people have known about for a long
time it's it's very stressful and it's a
human story too of what it feels like to
to deal with obligations in my case that
I felt obligated to you know commanded
to if you will to fulfill to my father
emits emits the you know kind of
adventure of a lifetime that I had
waited you know years to get down to and
would later bear fruit in the form of
you know a successfully done experiment
even though we did have to modify the
conclusions that we made and you know I
did end up losing my father and the book
is also kind of a meditation prompted by
Alfred Nobel of all people that you know
you should you should write your will
down you know the day before you die
meaning that you don't know when you're
gonna die so you should really have some
kind of document what Alfred Nobel did
is leave what's called an ethical will a
will that doesn't just give away his
material you know properties he had no
children no wife and so he gave away
almost all of his money to this prize if
there's his name in order to do good for
the world so he hoped and then you know
part of the story may be looking talking
about this next is what happened when I
was asked to nominate the winners of the
Nobel Prize and what I discovered at
that time
well III thought I thought that would be
exactly where I would go with next so
you've really kind of my own quote you
asked you asked my own question or I
love interviewing myself yeah you do a
great keeper my own favorite guest yeah
I could just so their Nobel Prize so the
Nobel Prize was was started because of
kind of an unusual turn of events and it
started with Alfred Nobel who was
basically they you know the Steve Jobs
or the you know it's a pioneer inventor
of the of the 1800s he had 300
fifty-five patents but his most
profitable one was for dynamite and
dynamite was used for construction but
also a lot of destruction and he was
tagged with being essentially a war
profiteer he sold armaments to all sides
in different battles throughout the
1800s and then towards the end of his
life in 1895 he was in 1888 he was
strolling around Paris by himself again
he never married he never had kids and
he found they saw a newspaper and it
said Alfred Nobel the merchant of death
is dead and it was kind of gleefully
celebrating that he had died the man who
was responsible according to this
headline of killing more people than any
other human being in history yeah and
they were celebrating it and he's
reading it so it's like Mark Twain said
the reports of my demise are slightly
exaggerated it was actually his older
brother Ludwig who had died and but he
realized it was kind of like George
Bailey and it's a wonderful life like he
had a second chance to redeem his name
the Nobel named and again he could do so
via this this prize so he gave this
prize and it was meant to be given to a
single person who discovered something
the preceding year that had the greatest
benefit on mankind those are his exact
words in his handwritten will that he
wrote down 1895 and then he died almost
11 months exactly later so had he not
you know really pursued it any any
faster we might not ever even know them
there are some companies that there that
name but but mainly it's the most kind
of celebrated award in human history
more so than you know the the
Nickelodeon TV Choice Award or whatever
it's it's taken on this huge importance
in society I just read something
yesterday that like 70 Nobel are
multiple Nobel laureates
and Madonna you know advised open
society and you know you've made it you
know when when Madonna is on the same
side as your Nobel Prize yeah absolutely
I mean you know I she may win a Nobel
Prize I think she will just for saying
that I mean Bob Dylan did so you know
she could win it as well anyway the the
point being that this award has such a
huge impact on society so the Year less
than a year
we had to retract our conclusion so
bicep didn't make him blunder it didn't
like oh we left the lens cap on right
right or we we said that the neutrinos
go faster than the speed of light that
didn't happen right
instead we measured something
exquisitely precisely and we attributed
the the origin of it to the wrong thing
so we actually measured something more
precisely than ever and even after
working we ended up working with clunk
and the Planck satellite which is this
billion euro satellite competitor they
never detected the primordial signal
either but they did detect the dust
really accurately and then by combining
bicep with Planck so bicep measured the
cosmic signal plus dust Planck really
just measured the cotton the dust signal
and then he could subtract the gusts
from the cosmic plus gusts of C plus D
minus D would leave you with a cosmic
signal leftover if there was one so we
now have a constraint we now say it
can't be bigger than a certain value of
energy in the ultra early universe
trillionth of a second after the Big
Bang and that is incredibly satisfying
and that experiment continues to this
day unlike you know other like cold
fusion no it doesn't really continue
there a couple people that do but you
know Trulia blunders for example would
not be continuing as I said this is now
you know six years after the
announcement and and more than that
experiments such as the Simon's
Observatory that I'm co-leading these
experiments are pursuing the same
signals with exactly the same ideas the
same types of technology not the exact
same technology but similar ideas are
refracting telescope located on a high
on a comet desert I'll show you a
picture of it Journal and what we're
trying to do is go and do the same thing
but measure dust and the cosmic signal
with the same experiment from the first
time and do that extremely accurately
and hopefully what will be left this is
where the site of the Simon's
Observatory is at 17,000 feet in Chile
there are some of the telescope's of the
Simon's array that are currently there
so we hope to measure both the cosmic
signals and the dust signals and finally
once and for all answer this question of
whether or not inflation occurred with a
certain properties or whether or not
other models such as what's called a
cyclic mode
it could that be more more
representative of the data and of the of
the physics of the early universe is
fascinating to be a part of it wouldn't
that be something to to know that you
know even after having to pull it back
then it can come back again and say
alright now that we've countered now
that we've corrected for Milky Way
polarization galactic polarization
here's the actual signal I mean so I
still hope
we only have a couple minutes left not
want to take up too much of your time
you've been so generous of generous with
it but bright it was anything I could
one thing I'd like to try to do here is
just maybe get to a question really
quick if you'll pay me as soon as I can
find this here
so you know what because there was a so
given all right so Stuart MacLean asks
given the axis of evil in the CMB that's
an interesting preface to the premise of
the question Stuart then surely you
would get different results from looking
at southern hemisphere versus the
northern hemisphere do you think you'd
see a different result if you look from
a different way on earth interesting
question oh that's a very very astute
question one that we don't have too much
time to talk about I'll put it up on my
screen here if I can get that going here
the axis of evil and essentially what
it's saying is that the universe that we
thought of as very isotropic is very
similar homogeneous it looks the same
that every individual location is not
the same you know this doesn't look
exactly like this over here but these
statistical properties are consistent no
matter if you look at the left side of
this plot versus the right side or the
top hemisphere versus the bottom and
that would be the case at the signals
purely cosmological in origin that we
should have the same properties but this
gentleman Stewart was it what yes um
what he's saying is something slightly
different which is what if it's true
that the universe has properties you
know kind of on the largest scales but
what if there are anomalies where
there's slightly more energy in in the
top half or on this side of the plot
over here versus here you know
red and blue and then even there could
be a spot that's really anomalous that's
shown over here finally got right so
there's a circle around the blue spot
over there that's anomalously cold so
one of my colleague blends Starkman at
Case Western in my alma mater is looking
exactly to understand whether or not
phenomena such as the axis of evil or
this excess of energy or could be a
signature of what's called topology that
the universe has has certain boundary
conditions that make it repeatable on
certain size scales much much larger
than the scale of our currently what we
call the currently observable universe
and some even say it could be harbinger
of things like the multiverse or of
extra dimensions these are beautiful
delicious things to speculate on right
now there isn't sufficient evidence to
say that the axis of evil' is truly you
know a durable a resilient effect or
whether it will go away with more
experiments of the kind that we're
trying to do say with the Simon's
Observatory fantastic you know this has
just been such a wonderful conversation
and I could just I can ask you like a
thousand more questions but what I what
I'll do is I think we'll go ahead and
just wanted to say where can people find
out more and I know you got a podcast I
want you to talk about plug it please
okay yeah so I've been doing this
podcast for the week all the arthur c--
clark center for human imagination here
at UC san diego i do all sorts of
different things interviews and events
and so forth and what i've been doing
lately since the corona virus struck
i've been doing i've been doing a lot of
podcasts with authors of books whose
books were basically canceled the book
tours were essentially cancelled because
of the corona virus and what i'm trying
to do now is really understand ways that
i could help them and promote their book
now i you know it's not true that
someone like peter diamandis really
needs brian Keating's help but he's a
friend and so we had him on the show and
today's episode is with him and he's
he's a brilliant thinker we talk about
we talk about things ranging from you
know how will education be affected how
we how we get get you know possibly
cures from scientific you know thought
around the world working together and
sort of against this invisible enemy
that we're trying to halt so this I'm
standing over Peter I shouldn't do that
but I'll stand over here it's called the
end of the impossible podcast if you go
to my web my youtube channel dr. Bryan
Keating Dr Bryan Keating on YouTube
you'll find it and you can go to my
website Bryan Keating comm and dr. Bryan
Keating on Twitter and and Instagram and
I post a lot of these interviews with
people that I'm blessed to have access
to like peter stephen wolfram eric
weinstein Sascha Segan Carl Sagan's
daughter is gonna be on my show Sunday
morning for Mother's Day so please tune
in and subscribe I I think folks here
you heard the man get to it and the book
is called losing the Nobel Prize I have
a link to this on Amazon or have a link
to the book on Amazon it's right in the
description of this video full
disclosure I do not have any affiliate
links with Amazon so that's okay right
it's a great book it really is a
wonderful read and Bryan thank you so
much for coming by today just to tell us
just a little bit about it and I hope I
hope you will consider you know just a
pointless my I hope you'll consider
coming back and we can geek out some
more because there's such a wonderful
university write about it so well sir
oh absolutely now I love I love my time
on the channel I can't wait to come back
and hopefully we'll do it again maybe do
a book review segment like I do with
Tony every so often I think that's a
capital idea so all I have to do now is
watch how you and Tony do that and then
steal everything that Tony says so I can
sound smarter soon like a great academic
the plagiarize don't let anything evade
your eyes in Tamil era so I want to
thank once again my guest dr. Bryan
Keating for coming by today to tell us
about his book losing the Nobel Prize
please definitely make sure you check it
out check out his podcast make sure that
you've given his given given his iTunes
RSS feed the proper subscription that I
so richly deserves and I want to thank
all of you for coming out today spending
a little bit of your time with me today
and and talking about the universe
thank you all so much and as always stay
home stay healthy and stay curious my
friends okay and we are out and awesome
well actually we're out now